hi everybody thank you so much for
joining us here at this wonderful bafta
q and a
uh the sky original that you can watch
um
on sky atlantic in sky now on the 27th
of august from 9 p.m
two episodes and then it will all be
available as well to watch
i've been lucky enough to watch two
episodes which is brilliant to be able
to chat to this wonderful panel about so
without further ado uh please welcome
lucy prebble the series writer
co-creator
and executive producer look at this
uh billy piper plays susie pickles
co-creator and executive producer
uh leila farzad who plays naomi suzy's
manager and best friend
so much to talk about uh and daniel ings
who plays
cop susie's husband georgie banks davies
the director
andrew jewsbury producer and myself um
hi everybody thank you so much for being
here
hi there hi there and we will give you
guys as well who are joining us the
chance to answer ask some questions i'm
going to selfishly dive in first and ask
all the questions i want to ask and you
can put yours
in the q a section i'll get through as
many of those as i possibly
can as well uh lucy
um where did this where and how did this
idea start i believe it was quite a
while ago the conversations or the seeds
of these
this character and this story started
yeah it was probably about five years
ago now
at least i think and um billy and i
were having a drink somewhere which
isn't unusual and had a conversation
um about something or other in life
i think something was going on in one of
our lives and i remember it was probably
the first time that billy said to me
you know we should do it we should try
and make a tv show again
because we have worked together
originally in a show called secret eye
of a cool girl many many years ago
and we were both much much younger and
um
we were having this conversation as as
friends and we started to
sort of think in a very casual way what
would it be if we were going to do that
it took quite a long time from that
point to come up with what eventually
became i hate susie but i wrote quite a
few versions of the first episode that
were really different from what it ended
up being
it was actually more of a sort of
friendship sitcom actually originally in
the very very early days between two
women
and then um but i kept having this
pervasive feeling of sort of
so what like so so what what's the thing
what's the thing
because i like something quite big and
meaty and dramatic to sort of get my
teeth into and
eventually i was sort of thinking and
chatting about never having actually
found out what happened in the case of a
lot of the women
who had had their um iclouds hacked if
you remember
back a number of years ago it was huge
and it was really
devastating and massive and and
upsetting and
and yet nothing nothing sort of
consequentially seemed to be in the news
after that which i always found really
sort of surprising and i don't just mean
criminally necessarily i mean more sort
of emotionally
um and professionally actually in terms
of them talking about it it felt like it
all had to go underground in a sort of
terrible state of shame
and so i started to think what would
that be like if your whole life was kind
of exploded
through these images and that's kind of
where the idea originally
came from billy why did why did you want
to um
why did you was actually first of all
how did you find
creating susie because you know we start
this we start the series and
and the clever and brilliant thing that
you've done is each episode is almost
an emotion or a reaction to her
experience but
it kind of very much feels that she
doesn't really know who she is
herself in a way and was that an
exciting opportunity to create a
character like that that almost she's on
a journey of discovery throughout this
entire series
yeah um absolutely and i think
the hack was a great way to unmask
this woman um and this character and
certainly
um chimed with a lot of conversations
that lucy and i had been having about
your late 20s early 30s being this sort
of rude awakening
and how quite often and certainly
conversations i've had and
amongst my friends he's sort of uh
a common theme seems to be i don't know
who i really am i don't
know i do you know i feel like i
should be more established at this point
or um
i am sort of established in the eyes of
the world and actually i don't want any
of that
and i am constantly
trying to appeal to people but who am i
and this was a great
way that was a great advice in terms of
exposing
um a woman and what it is we sort of go
through
from birth until you know late 20s early
30s which feels also like something we
don't talk a great deal about so we took
a great deal about our 20s
um but then you
oh police forces that gives a lot
you know that gives us a lot to sort of
play with
and yeah this awful incriminating
thing happens um but it sort of
it it it helps her find herself
ultimately so where do we explain to
people who maybe haven't seen it yet
where we find
susie pickles at the start of this this
series
um well please
oh um so the show the show basically
opens with her life
um which is living with her
lovely handsome husband cobb played by
dan
who's kind enough to be here today and
uh
very handsome very handsome
and and basically she seems to have this
pretty
good life ostensibly um she has
a very close friend who is also her
manager uh naomi jones played by
uh the beautiful layla um so i have to
say beautiful very
beautiful but now i'm right now
this is what people are like in the show
no um it's and
she everything seems to be fine in fact
she gets this this this bit of good news
at the beginning of episode one which is
she's going to
play a disney princess in a new um
movie and she can't quite believe it she
thought her career was on the skis
anyway and then throughout the course of
episode one it becomes clear that
something else has happened which is
a mass leak of stolen images
in which she's included which is going
to affect every area of her life and the
episodes basically
roll through the different areas of her
life that it affects in hopefully
unexpected and interesting ways that you
might not necessarily assume
um emotionally and professionally
particularly and each of the episodes
and georgie the director can speak quite
a lot to this i think because this was
one of the great
things that um you know she brought to
the show which was the
you know the way of visualizing how each
of the episodes should feel different
because they're each stages that susie
goes through in dealing with this
kind of violation and trauma and
exposure
yeah i think in episode one as well
she's sort of hysterically holding
everything
together and um that we very
quickly learn um
you know that she's um i would say kind
of
quite on the edge um
and then you know these things happens
and it totally blows
everything apart and that's you know
that's satisfying
hopefully to watch but certainly to play
that claus scene in episode one is
amazing i sing it for a reason obviously
and that is just it it's so it's
so good it kind of
it totally
surprises you and i think
that's
there's an incredible emotional truth to
it but
you never quite know where this of what
it's going to bring you as a product
about
i guess your reaction to the story and
how you wanted to kind of represent it
visually
sorry edith was that to me slightly
broken yeah sorry yeah george you just
wanted to try and get yeah
an idea of kind of how you reacted to
the script and and
and how you saw that kind of
representation visually and trying to
really bring it to
you know to life well lucy writes sort
of
incredibly like in depth so i really
remember like once
our ad had put a schedule together for a
day and he was like just one scene and i
was like have you read it
it's like five scenes mate in one it's
kind of the best way to
describe it in that it's so layered it
and so when you just read the source
material it's like
you read it once as a director and then
you read it again and you read between
the lines and then again
again and you know she has a beautiful
tapestry in the way that she writes like
that and
which is um it's such a great starting
point and
i think like like lucy said it
is it was it's very exciting to look at
something where you can play
with every episode in a different way
and emotionally in a different way
so it kind of started there really i was
like i just i just looked at lots and
lots of reference and thought okay we've
got two tasks here which felt quite
unusual one is like what's the look and
the style of the show
and secondary it's like what's the look
and style of every episode so
what's the glue that holds us together
and of course you know that's also billy
and leila and dan and nat and all the
great actors who hold the characters
through the through line
but then visually like how do we play
and how do we explore but i had one very
simple rule and that was that
we are always in susie's perspective and
that
and that can be literally or it can be
emotionally but that we never
never ever can are allowed behind her or
in front of her as an audience
because you have to live this
emotionally and as soon as you kind of
may as soon as i sort of
made that rule if you like it everything
became easier
and it means also that you can be really
experimental you can be fantastical
you can kind of go anywhere you want to
go if legitimately the character goes
there and you've seen the second episode
i mean oh yeah
there's one particular scene that it's
they told me not to swear but you know
she's pretty [ __ ] up and it's like
it's just caveat and like physically
there's a lot of drinking drugs involved
and it's like so again as a director
you're like
okay well i'm in this character's
perspective so i'm in her perspective
and and you get to sort of use all the
tools and all the filmmaking kind of
like
playfulness to really project that
so it's it's a really unique project
like that i mean it's like a dream
project as a director and i think that
all those elements as well really kind
of almost kind of
really get to the depth of her kind of
you know despair almost at times as well
you know the kind of the
the almost kind of fantastical elements
of it kind of really heightened
how you see her emotionally i think as a
viewer
for sure yeah totally and we don't just
you know uh beyond episode two we sort
of we
i i'd like to think it will continually
surprise the audience because if you
ever think you've got a hold of it
it hopefully will just spin you 180
again
yeah and it just we just got to play so
many different genres so
um i'm excited if you want to watch past
episode two
yeah and layla naomi in episode two we
learned quite a lot about naomi in
episode two
um but what you do discover is that
these
these two characters are kind of you
know they've been friends for a very
long time they've been through a lot
together was that kind of almost was
that a nice thing to
talk to me if you and billy kind of
talked about that and worked on that in
terms of
talking about kind of what went on
before we find them
you know in terms of how that brings us
to where they are now
i think female friendship is not like
really examined very much
and how um if you've been friends with
someone since you were very little
you sort of get stuck and you're not
there's not much room for you to evolve
as people and so there's a lot of love
between these two women
but i think sometimes they don't like
each other
and that's quite unpalatable for for
most people
i don't know there's um the friendship
is
is very interesting it's it's
codependent and um
naomi sort of lives for for susie
um which is an act of love but also
slightly
um self-effacing so it's very confused
and susie does love naomi but it's it's
new it's very layered
what was your reaction when you when you
first read the script
oh my god i i want to be in this
when i first first read it um yeah
excited
and just recognizing it it's like yes
finally it's ugly and it's flawed and
it's
grotesque at points and that's just what
we're like and
people just want to polish everything up
and make everything neat and it's such a
relief to read something
that's both clever and true
um so yes i was very excited when i read
it
and john can we talk a little bit about
cobb um
how would you describe him um
he is a very
repressed man
he's in this he's in this
marriage which he needs and which he
relies on and i think he's managed to
sort of convince himself
um that he is in charge of the situation
i think and
particularly on a sort of emotional
level
and i guess susan cobb sort of box
themselves into this place where their
marriage is
is um in some ways quite comfortable
and that in the issues between them are
never addressed
and um and i guess throughout the course
of the series you know it seems at first
that he's quite a sort of doting
parent and husband then i guess as the
series goes on you realize that that's
not
that's not the whole story um there's a
lot of anger there
and a lot of um there's a lot of
resentment i think
that he feels like he i think there's
there's this kind of ceiling resentment
that he's already been emasculated by
the fact that his wife is so much more
successful than him
that she's the breadwinner and so i
suppose when this
um this kind of what he says like he
sees
like an injury to him through the phone
hacking when that happens i think that
brings up a lot of
um latent rage
yeah it's the quiet bubbling that you
even get kind of in
you know between episode two it's just
simmering
and you're like oh wow yeah i mean
the the simmeringness of it is is
largely due to
the fact that um georgie's a good
director and and uh
lucy is a good writer i m my instinct
was always to sort of
um push the rage because it was so fun
and i think
i think you know what what what georgie
did so cleverly was was kind of make
sure that that
was that that was sort of held in and
withheld you know and that you get
glimpses of it and
more and more as it goes on yeah um
andrew in terms of of
you know producing a show like this what
are they
what are the biggest challenges because
you know as georgie was thinking of each
each episode has its own kind of sort of
not aesthetic but it's got it's it's
kind of own uniqueness in a way is is
that a kind of joy as a producer in
terms of the challenges that that throws
up
yeah absolutely i think i think the show
is really interesting because although
it's a very intimate story
it's it's very ambitious in terms of the
sheer amount of locations and cast
and then you meet a director like
georgie who comes in and goes it's
already ambitious but what i want to do
on top of that
is basically make a series that also
contains an element almost of of
individual films but they're all still
hold together like this beautiful series
um so yeah it's a real joy it's a
challenge but you go
oh yeah this is going to be this is
going to be great
when when you have something that is
that that is kind of really sort of
direct and honest and you know you have
a channel involved and you have a
production
um company involved as well
it feels like watching it that you were
really allowed to make the show that you
wanted
to make in terms of is that an
is that an easy thing to achieve at the
minute and did you were you able to make
the show that you wanted to make
um yes i think we had i think
um skye and bad wolf
everyone understood what was so special
about this project
um everyone understood that the
collaboration between lucy and billy was
just the heart of it and the heart of
everything and
that was always kind of the thing we
always returned to and we were really
lucky that we had
billy and lucy on set with us the whole
time
um so yeah you know
we've all been asked about you know was
it difficult to get this past the
channel or that past the channel and
actually
we didn't really have those sort of
conversations obviously everything went
through compliance as it always does but
everyone was was everyone was so on the
same page actually
it was it's sorry it's a very dull
answer but actually
we were very very very supported i think
yeah it's and that's really unusual
i think in my experience anyway i mean
there were
there are obviously exceptions to that
and you think about some of the big
streamers and stuff who sort of pride
themselves on saying here's the money go
away and make what you
want to make but i don't know how true
that is
firstly and secondly that's really
difficult to do in this country where
there's so
little money comparatively and there's
so little sort of time and
it's and we're under different sorts of
stresses and pressures
so it was yeah it was pretty great
there were suggestions and there were
sometimes you know thoughts
but i i felt pretty much for the first
time in my career on screen i think
that there was a sort of understanding
that
we that we were going to make
be able to make the show that we wanted
to make because actually originally
we'd come and said here's what the show
is i think and it hadn't been one of
those processes where you spent
ages and ages like in rooms having
meetings trying to sort of convince each
other you've got the same vision
because we had sort of written some of
it before and then
sort of gave it and said here's what we
sort of think it is and
that that makes a huge difference but
kia kudos to sky
for allowing that and and doing that and
i think that actually
industry-wise it's quite a good move
because i feel like the
one of the great advantages of getting
artists to work here rather than going
to those big streams is going to be
saying creatively
you know if if we're not going to spend
that massive massive amount of money
we're going to actually offer you um
creative
powers and control and sort of stuff
like that and yeah i feel very grateful
for that
um billy i wanted to ask you as well
because i think that there's a there's
such a brilliant
honesty that you can see in in the
portrayal of the character
and whether you know she's obviously
someone who's in the public eye and
she's someone who's been in the public
eye
for a young age but you can also you
know just look at her on a human level
sort of thing as well
but i think that one of the things
that's brilliant is peeling back that
kind of
veneer of celebrity in a way you know in
terms of showing her as a mother
to uh to you know a young boy who
um who is uh is deaf
and and you know and and having you know
not everything being right and and was
it important for you to have the chance
to kind of do that in a way you know
being someone who's been in the public
eye from a young age and
you know there's nothing you know
biographical about this but i imagine
quite a lot of your experience is kind
of poured into so much of this show
yeah i think it's just for me as an
an actor it's just it's just important
that
um women are represented on screen
whether they're
playing a famous person or just
you know or a mother or someone whatever
it is
it really spins me out when
that is done inauthentically i i
really passionately hate it and i feel
it's such a wasted
a wasted moment and so for me just the
quest
to constantly um drive through to
um something that feels
you know at times horribly honest um
and you know potentially very exposing
but i i i think you know i
both lucy and i i think share this sort
of quest which is we
we want to we want to be we want people
to be able to relate to it and i think
one of our concerns
at the beginning was oh she's it's we
we're using a
we're drawing from a famous person's
life but actually
on some level nowadays we all have
something to lose because we all have a
very
weirdly we have this now public profile
yeah um just by being on social media
really i think
um everything you know anything could be
incriminating on some level
and um it was important that
for us that when people watch that it's
not
distancing um as an experience that it's
something that they can relate to so
certainly all the emotional stuff was
really
you know integral and um yeah
yeah yeah i think um one of the things
that we'd often
ask each other at the beginning of the
process was what do you see what do you
experience a lot in life but you never
see it on television
and that's often a place that i find
very fruitful to write from
and i remember there's this moment in
the last episode of the show where she's
where she's quite unpleasant to her son
and i remember standing round the
monitor when we
when we were filming it and and somebody
going oh god that's
horrible and then and i said oh is it is
it
is that what your experience of that is
and she said yeah
i said no it's possible oh yeah you said
yes but the other mothers around the
monitor or
when i said yeah but have you ever do
you so you're saying you never would
talk like that to your son and they went
oh no yeah i do all the time i just mean
it's it's horrible
on screen and it's moments like that
where you go
oh brilliant brilliant then this is what
we want because you've got all these
people going oh yeah oh yeah at least
once a week but not on television
and that's the moment i'm interested in
that's so true there are yeah absolutely
well i think that's about the whole
thing about the emotional truth that you
get from
the show to be honest um lucy was
important for you
to be kind of you know were you there
whilst the whole thing was being filmed
sort of thing is that
yeah but i'm you know i'm a controlling
nightmare i mean i'm
constantly there like i love you like
every moment yeah
just just a little bit down a little bit
down
oh no i'm yeah like bill bring it
i feel like that was a note to me lucy
no i mean yeah yes i am i'm no i can't
excuse it but you know
it's it's how you you know i don't know
i just worked really hard on it and i
didn't want
to party without me
you didn't want to miss out on the fun
did you that's the thing do you know how
boring writing is
compared to that it's so boring
was there was there a kind of
encouragement to or did you have this to
the time and space to
to improvise on set or to kind of play
with scenes and
georgie was that something that you were
interested in in looking into or
or not i love it i mean i've sort of got
an ephos of actors which is like
let them own the character you know and
then and then i want to guide them
through
the world but i don't want to tell them
who they are like let them really own it
and
billy's like a master class of that i
learnt so much from her because that's a
general mo you know
and um i think so then
yeah yes yes and no you know it was
always lucy was always there so we just
we
we talked about those things there's
certain scenes where
it would spin off i mean i think all of
the actors hate me because i never say
cut
and i'm just forcing them to at the end
of every take there's always something
brilliant because
they just have to keep going like billy
i remember once when you were like
i can see you like you should get a
[ __ ] time
there's only so much improving i can do
but what it does is it like allows this
sort of like
beautiful and i'm always looking for
like the kind of extra
just letting them really building a
space so however technical we get and
however
um orchestrated something gets the what
i always want to do is make sure that
the actors don't feel that and that they
have the ultimate freedom to just
really like play and i don't mind if
it's different
every time i in fact i encourage that
it's like focus bullets hate me because
i won't
allow marks to go down i don't want to
block it but i but within that there's a
really grand master plan and i think
improv sort of played in and out of that
it had to work for this
for the episode so episode six for
example which is
guilt and is based upon for me
stylistically and
kind of much more of a social realism
vibe
it plays a little bit more with the day
players in terms of improv
and so yeah yes to a certain extent
where it was right
but it always came back down to the
central right i mean lucy probably wrote
the show you don't
like the words are always brilliant and
then you you know
we explored beyond that a little bit
here and there
i am that photo shoot in the first
episode
is is an extraordinary piece of
of film it's just you know and those
those shots of your face billy in terms
of
you you just see it's so emotional it's
so hard to watch but you can't
not watch it because you yeah it's
it's so great congratulations on that
alone because i just thought it was
extraordinary
oh thanks i mean talk about comic-con
yeah yes so you actually went
to comic-con is this right yeah we went
to
we went to the i i forget the official
name of it now but the london
comic-con and we we took over uh
we took over a space and um we had our
own
setup with our own big poster in the
background of courvardis and our own
audience and our own
um you know strange sci-fi costumes
and our own hosts um
lucy didn't decide to be honest herself
you
i'm a sci-fi fan so i was there going
like i
this is this is the show i want to make
this pretend though that we've done all
this design for we've put his massive
face on
and that's not true and it was
it was yeah that was really fun and we
also had a lot of fun i think um
leila the like was in when we did that
scene in the hotel room we got an actual
hotel
obviously to do it in but you know the
idea being it was attached to comic-con
and i we i think that was one of our one
of our best
one of our finest hours actually that
whole section i don't know what um
i don't know but yeah that was and
sorry it's like 101 dalmatians
um and yeah so so it was it was really
really really fun to
do um i think it was quite fun to act as
well
am i wrong yeah the hotel room was a lot
of fun
i mean i've had a great time thanks to
fletcher
oh my god so good oh my god
when he came on i was like yes
yeah it's brilliant casted as well for
that has that been
was that a fun side to it as well in
terms of because
i've only seen you know the first two
sort of thing but but i mean
you know even like that little moment
was just brilliant
was that were you writing specifically
with people in mind for things well you
were thinking about
you know little characters that were in
there um
even like the camera crew you know doing
the photo shooting stuff that was just
perfectly pitched oh thank you yeah i
mean obviously some of that's writing
some of that
is performance and a lot of its
direction as well which is
you sort of you make sure that every
single person that comes on the screen
at any moment
has a very full life and
you know i always love and i always love
actors who will come on and go
here's the story of this person that you
see for 15 seconds by the way just in
case you're interested that i've come up
with and they brought it to set and that
sometimes happens and that's always
really
you know actually sounds like a wanky
thing to say but sort of humbling in a
way because as a writer what you realize
is
you sort of wanted them there for this
plot point and they've actually done a
load of work that really elevates
it and i'm always grateful for that
because frankly it makes everyone look
better
um well this we've got loads of
questions that are coming in as well
from people so i want to get through as
many as we can and
we've got one from liam who says this is
a great one actually and
what was it like working with bsl
translator brian duffy on the deaf
character of frank suzy's son and why
did you decide to include a deaf
character in this series
sure well i um
obviously frank was written as deaf i
was
i was interested in the fact that they
had a kid together cobb and susie
um i thought it made the marriage more
interesting and also it made the dynamic
of her being an actress and a mother it
was another role for her to play
essentially and to get wrong um as well
as right
and i and i sort of just wanted to make
that as interesting as possible
and also again it was that question of
what do you see a lot of in life that
you never see done on screen in a
particular way and
i was interested in seeing somebody who
was deaf on screen done in a way that
because i have a
friend of mine who is deaf and she's
just
always very very funny about what it is
that's funny about being deaf
you know and the things she gets away
with as a result of it and things like
that
and i was like well that you never
really see could he be quite a naughty
boy
you know and that or this that on the
other and and
anyway so it was just a way of being
inspired by putting something on screen
it was actually dan who did a lot of the
work with sign language and stuff like
that because we decided that cobb maybe
was better at
that i don't know if you want to talk
about working on that down
yeah for sure yeah so we we just well
lucy decided that
uh cobb would be more proficient at sign
language
and it was this interesting thing where
it was like
in a way it became like a stick to sort
of beat susie with
that he could communicate with his son
in a way that she couldn't you know and
i think so he
committed to that um in this incredible
way for all of his flaws so i worked
with brian duffy
for about six weeks i want to say maybe
like two or three times a week
and we became good pals he was on set
throughout the shoot as well
and it was you know it's always just
like a joy to have to be able to sort of
dive into something extra like
that's one of the coolest things i think
about being an actor is when you get to
like
learn an instrument or learn a bit of a
language like oh
obviously i didn't have enough time to
learn the whole of bsl um
which uh which would have been awesome
but um particularly because lucy preble
is always rewriting
um but um so we had to figure out some
of that on the fly
but it was wicked you know um it was
interesting
talking to duffy about he was saying
that
it's rare for parents of a deaf child to
be able to speak sign language properly
and so the example he gave was that like
his own parents don't really speak like
sign language they have their own kind
of like signs and symbols for things
um that basically mean nothing or means
something completely else in bsl
so it was interesting to be able to
portray a character in that way that
like
maybe isn't uh is is kind of rare
and there's a responsibility there i
think i don't know if you felt this as
well bill there's a responsibility there
to get it right you know what i mean to
not i what i didn't want to do
was to be like supposedly doing
brilliant sign language in the show
and for people to watch it afterwards
and be like that guy's
talking gibberish um so there was a bit
of a responsibility there
we committed to it
um we've got another question um if you
are putting questions and just put your
name in even one name
you can make up a name if you want
anonymous attendee is really dull
and this is from an anonymous attendee
it says um
will there continue to be musical
numbers throughout
it gives it a unique and surprising feel
uh was that an idea that came early on
thank you anonymous
i think lucy and i are destined to do a
musical together because
we're both sort of obsessed with them
some of the more obscure ones um um
and i'm always clucking to sort of sing
and dance on screen
um so i often ask
lucy to um you know can i dance in this
scene
and this evening i just obey her because
apparently i have no will of my own
yeah yeah i mean yeah we do
you know although that is actually quite
an inspiring thing you know when an
actor sort of says to you listen i
really really want to do this thing
it's quite a fun game in your head to go
well how could i possibly do that how
could that happen
um and at least it gives you something
to aim towards
um but yeah the the the i'm afraid that
the truthful and disappointing answer is
that
no there were not loads and loads of
song advanced numbers throughout but
what i would say
is that each episode has an element that
is
as extraordinary and bizarre and
fantastical it's just that that changes
depending on what the
emotion of the episode is is that fair
george
yeah totally totally and we're not going
to give it away you're just going to
have to wait and see
i'm looking forward to i still hate
susie the musical
[Laughter]
this is another anonymous attendee lucy
aside from billy were you writing with
particular actors
in mind can you talk a little bit about
the casting process
yeah sure um yeah no i
i i wasn't writing with particular
actors in mind i'm trying to think back
i was thinking of the character mostly i
remember
um dan
jumped out immediately like dan when we
met down and we watched a a i watched a
video first
where he was kind enough to do a reading
the scene and
immediately i thought this person is not
commenting on the character in the way
that sometimes it's easy to do
i think sometimes when you write men in
shows
about women or that just happen to have
women in them
you know that there can sometimes be
this tendency to go okay so is he
this terrible terrible villain monster
that we sort of gonna laugh at
or is he this sort of very very nice guy
that everyone
you know sort of loves that sort of gets
shot on and that does that often is a
kind of
broad sitcom thing that goes on with the
casting and the writing of men and
what i wanted to try and do although
obviously i'm always you know a woman
trying to write a man
i was trying to write a guy who was
difficult
in a lot of ways but wasn't totally
unlikable and actually who you could
understand a lot of his aspects i don't
know what you think dan i think there
are occasions with cobb where i'm like
quite on his side actually even though i
think he has issues with how he
expresses himself and anger particularly
is that fair
yeah i mean it's definitely he's
definitely going through stuff as well
and and loads of the
emotions that he's feeling are totally
legitimate i think his behavior is
pretty reprehensible but he's not an out
and out bad guy
and i do think um yeah it's interesting
to hear you say that about the fact that
if you flip it and you look at how so
many male writers write
female characters and you know this is a
pretty obvious comment but they're so
often
incredibly two-dimensional and i think
that it's
yeah it's so interesting to see that
like
once you have um
women getting the opportunity to write
these shows that the male characters the
same the same is not true the other way
around
do you know what i mean and that's nice
for you to say
yeah no but you know that's what drew me
to is it's
such a complex character and i uh
yeah and i think that that needs to be
the case more often
no no that's that's really nice because
you never know that's honestly what i
meant is because you don't know because
you can never be that
you know you never quite know i remember
the first time i saw
that like the first time i saw the adam
driver character on girls
i was like oh my god it's a man written
by a woman like it was
first time i remember going i know who
that guy
is and it's not that men have been
obviously men have been writing men
brilliantly for centuries but
that was the first time i sort of
recognized a woman's take on a man that
was
different from what i'd seen before
because it was through her eyes um
yeah and anyway i'd love to talk to i'd
love like i
when layla came in and did naomi it was
very brilliant because
i have to be honest and say that there
are elements of naomi that have probably
come a little bit from
myself a tiny bit like there's an over
cerebral nerve sometimes a kind of
like over reliance on the on the
theoretical
and need to control if you can imagine
such a thing and um
and i think that must have been you know
layla's very smart i must have realized
that fairly early on i wonder what what
that was like
[Music]
oh oh later she's not i thought i
thought she's no no i'm not answering
that's how i felt um
yes she's she's um fiercely bright
like lucy and um unflappable
and in charge and but also vulnerable
and human and makes mistakes so
it was it was a challenge and and
hopefully quite a recognizable
person to to see on screen
and a foil to suzy in a way how did you
come to be involved in the project how
did you first come you know
come to hear of it and get involved
well i i sent in um a terrible tape
uh first time round uh as an audition
and i was told that it was not no good
so i sent in another tape
and um because i thought when i read
naomi i was like no i know her
i know her i know how i can do her um
because
um as much as terrorist wife and all
that sort of great stuff that i'd also
been put up for was um
in my in my world this was very exciting
and then eventually i met billy and then
i met lucy and
um i guess something clicked and i was
sort of a real pinch myself pinch
yourself
moment um of going oh my god oh my god
i can't believe it because it was brave
and mad and
makes you question stuff and it's just
such a delight to be in it
i think that was the hardest part
to cast i think georgie lucy
we were we were in all of those
classrooms we were going
round the houses with it it's a really
it's it's hard it's a hard part and it's
in it's hard to do again authentically
sometimes because
um you know um it's
i don't know i i basically we met
layla at the what felt like a weeks and
weeks of looking
and um she came in and
she had she had all the cerebral
wit and and smarts and drive
but she has this really she has this dry
sense of humor which felt
yeah it was the show it was so much what
we wanted because
lucy and i very you know also kept our
eye on the fact that there is a version
of this script and it's not uh
um it's not to do lucy's writing out at
all but there is a version of this
script where
where these cat where people would come
in let's say and played these characters
and very
broadly and so it would feel like we
were in a sitcom and as much as we love
our sitcoms
we didn't want it to feel like that we
didn't want it to feel like a british
sitcom we wanted it to feel
um different and um
and so we so that that's that's that's
that's hard that's hard to find and
layla
absolutely nailed that and um
we got very excited because we were very
tired at that point
yeah it was like it was like one of
those moments where you're like maybe
there's something wrong with the
characters no no
no no no no no no no no no no i can play
i just
shut up maybe i said that once
and then that was completely rejected
and then they say no offense babe but i
don't want to direct you
yeah no quite right and leila came in
and it was like
christmas a little bit it was like oh
thank you such a good someone can be
like someone can do that and that and
that and
and yeah sometimes that happens
sometimes it happens really early
sometimes
it's really really late and you just
sort of go oh thank god
you know because we don't have to
reconceive the entire show yeah
yeah and i think to add to that it's
like we with all of the cast because we
had
we've got a big cast it's like it was a
long process but when they kept like
when dan arrived like
lucy said when layla arrived it was just
like yes
it's brilliant brilliant actors who can
like step up but
you know we're gonna we're gonna make
something and it's gonna be very special
so it was kind of it was worth all the
pain of the waiting i mean we saw
loads of brilliant actors it was just
there was something very magical about
these two alongside you know alongside
billy
um rebecca clark says what do you hope
the audience take away from the show
maybe a sense of um
relief although i don't know yeah maybe
some relief that i don't know i i feel
like
it would be nice if people walked away
when
i get i i get that it's not my life
entirely moment to moment but i get that
and i'm
and and that feels good and also
has a laugh and also has a real
um that it's an experience for them
because we
we wanted it to feel like that we wanted
it to feel immersive and georgie does
that
so well certainly in the first two
episodes
it's like you know it you you
you're sort of feeling all the fabric
and i think that's um
i hope people experience that too
um and then faye watson says is the
series a contained story
or would you like to continue to explore
it in a second series
well we shall have to see i mean if you
pencils
you know well i you know yeah i'd have
to
you know i'd have to come up with
something
and they'd have to want it and people
have to bought it so you know we'll yeah
we'll see but um
yeah it's it's been a lot of fun this
one
and and then we've got this just quickly
this one this is really just a quick and
pick up from an anonymous attendee
on their improv um uh leila daniel and
billy
how do you approach improv do you get
much rehearsal time
and you like it
um well and georgie and i and
we had some improv sort of sessions
before we started filming where we got
to do
character work which i found invaluable
and brilliant
and that was so that was before filming
and then there were little trigger words
that she would just say to me and it
would get me back into the brain of
naomi which i found
brilliant and incredibly helpful so
that's one of the examples of improv
that we have
yeah i don't think there wasn't we
didn't do a huge amount of
improvising on on set really like it's
the script is so tight it's so tightly
worded and tight plotted there wasn't a
huge amount of room for that but i i
guess
um in my head there were maybe like two
or three of the really emotional scenes
um between cobb and susie i remember
like a few where
it was just useful to not have to worry
if
um if you're really going to a dark
place and something weird comes out
there's like a few that spring to mind
and um you know but it wasn't like
improv so much as just like a
just a weird little moment or something
that may not have been scripted but it
is
it's all to be honest i mean i love
improvising
um but there wasn't for me there wasn't
really improvising this it's all just
like it's all in
it's all in the writing man
um listen we've run out of time and and
i just wanted to
give the final um question what's even a
question but tommy dress up who says
let's all keep dancing which i really
like the sentiment of
perfect that's right yeah um thank you
so much
to you all for taking the time to um to
to join us tonight it's been so lovely
to kind of just pick your brains about
you know this
series which i think is fantastic and uh
it's going to be available in sky
atlantic and now tv on the 27th of
august the sky original i hate susie
thank you so much to our wonderful thank
thank you guys thanks everyone thank you
so much
stay safe guys thank you bye
[Music]
you